let's say that we have the differential
equation
d y
d x with the derivative of y with
respect to x is equal to negative x
over y
let's say we don't know how to find the
solutions to this but we at least want
to get a a sense of what the solutions
might look like
and to do that what we could do is we
could look at a coordinate plane
so
let me draw some axes here
so let me
draw relatively straight line all right
so that's my y-axis
and this is my x-axis
let me do draw let me mark this as 1.
that's 2
that's negative 1
negative 2
negative 1
and negative 2.
and what i could do is since this
differential equation is just in terms
of x's and y's and first derivatives of
y with respect to x
i could go i could sample points on the
coordinate plane i could look at the x
and y coordinates substitute them in
here figure out what the slope is going
to be and then i could visualize the
slope if a solution goes to that point
what the slope needs to be there and i
can visualize that with a line segment a
little small line segment that has the
same slope as the slope in question so
let's actually do that so let me set up
a little table here
let me do a little table here to do a
bunch of x and y values once again i'm
just sampling some points on the
coordinate plane to be able to visualize
so x
y and this is d y
d x
so let's say when x is
let's say when x is 0 and y is 1 what is
the derivative of y with respect to x
it's going to be negative 0 over 1. so
it's just going to be 0.
and so at the point 0 1 if a solution
goes through this point its slope is
going to be 0 and so we can visualize
that by doing a little horizontal line
segment right there so let's keep going
what about when x is 1
and y is one
well then d y d x the derivative of y
with respect to x is negative one over
one so it's going to be negative one so
at the point one comma one
if a solution goes through that point it
would have a slope
it would have a slope of
negative 1. so i draw a little line
segment that has a slope of negative 1.
what about when x is let me do this in a
new color what about when
x is 1 and y is 0.
well then it's negative 1 over
0. so this is actually undefined
but it's a clue that maybe
maybe the slope there i guess or if you
had a tangent line at that point maybe
it's vertical so
so i'll put that as a question mark
vertical
there and so maybe it's something like
that if you actually did have i guess it
wouldn't be a function if you had some
kind of relation that went through it
but let's just put let's not draw that
just yet but let's try some other points
let's say that we had
let's try the point
negative 1
negative 1.
so now we have negative negative 1 which
is 1 over negative 1 well you would have
a slope of negative 1 here so negative 1
negative 1 you would have a slope
of
you would have a slope of negative 1.
what about if you had one negative one
well now it's negative one over negative
one your slope is now one so one
negative one if your solution if a
solution goes through this its slope
would look like that and we could keep
going we could even do 2 negative 2
that's going to have a slope of 1 as
well if you did
if you did positive 2 positive 2 that'd
be negative 2 over 2 you'd have a slope
of negative one right over here
and so we could do a bunch of
we could do a bunch of points just keep
going i've now i'm not just doing them
in my head i'm not going on the table
but you get a sense of what's going on
here here your slope would if is
negative one one
it's going to have a slope of 1.
so at this point your slope
negative 1 1. so negative negative 1 is
1 over 1 so you have slope like that at
negative 2 2 same exact
idea it would look like that and so you
get a when you keep drawing these line
segments over at these kind of these
sampled points in the cartesian or in
the in the xy plane
you start to get a sense of well what
would a solution have to do
and you can start to visualize that hey
maybe a solution a solution would have
to do something
something
like
this this would be a
a solution so maybe it would have to do
something like this or if we're looking
if we're looking only at functions and
not relations you know i'll only
i'll make it so it's a very clear
so maybe we would have to do something
like this or if
if the function started like here
based on what we've seen so far maybe
we'd have to do something
maybe we'd have to do something
like this
or if it was
if this were a point on the function
over here it would have to do
something like this and once again i'm
doing this based on what the slope field
is telling me
so this field that i'm creating where
i'm taking i'm sampling a bunch of
points and i'm visualizing the slope
with a line segment once again this is
called
a slope
slope
field
so hopefully that gives you kind of the
basic idea of what a slope field is in
the next few videos we'll explore this
idea even deeper